you
I thought I'd talk a little football
while I'm here I'm a big LSU fan and
we've only have one loss and y'all only
have one loss so I think maybe there
might be a Sugar Bowl in in the in the
future for the two teams I'd be fun I
first met Richard Scrushy in the summer
of 1980 I was living in Houston Texas
and I've recently passed the CPA exam
and I wanted to go to work for a large
company a publicly held company
I'd always worked for rather small and I
answered an ad in the paper and it was
for controller position at Life mark
corporation life mark was a publicly
held hospital company and I went in for
the interview and it was with Richard
Scrushy and I never met anybody quite
like Richard aldair in the interview my
head was just spinning I just couldn't
believe the person that he was and by
the end of the interview I was totally
convinced that that was the best job I
could possibly get in Houston Texas but
as I was driving home I kept thinking
about the interview and when I got home
I told my wife I said I think today I've
met the most brilliant businessman I'm
ever going to meet or maybe the biggest
con artist I'll ever meet and that's
actually been quoted in the Wall Street
Journal in the New York Times and a lot
of other publications but he did he
offered me the job I've reported him
work I got to work my first day I was
there about 30 minutes early and he came
into my office and he said Erin he said
I'm presenting a contract to my boss and
I'd like for you to sit in on my
presentation it's a contract I think we
should sign and I went in he introduced
me to his boss and he said error and
then I worked on the contract for hours
last night and I hadn't worked on
anything I barely stepped in the front
door and today I realized that he
probably told that lie to size me up to
see how I would react to being included
in a lie at the time I didn't think that
much about it
but I know a lot more about Richard
Scrushy now and I'm sure he told that
lie on purpose I worked for Rachel for
almost four years at life mark we
managed departments within hospitals we
would contract with hospitals to run
their respiratory therapy physical
therapy and pharmacies and Richard was
just amazing he could go into a little
hospital in Arkansas or somewhere and
walk in and walk out with three
contracts to run big revenue centers in
their hospitals and we'd take a percent
of the money and but I also learned that
he was had a real dark side he was so
into himself I remember many times
sitting in his office and he'd be
ranting and raving about a problem he
was having with his ex-wife or his boss
and it was always about Richard never
about me he just always about him in the
summer of 1983 I picked up the Wall
Street Journal one morning read and it
said life mark to be acquired by a mi a
much larger hospital company out of
California and the article said they'd
be closing the offices of life market
and I thought I don't know man I'm going
to be without a job but what happens
many times these are two New York Stock
Exchange companies and a lot of times
when they merge a venture capitalists
will approach the companies being bought
out in life market was clearly being
bought out and Citicorp venture capital
contacted bill backe the chairman of the
board in acid does anybody have an idea
for a start-up company to take it back
and bill Macki said Richard Scrushy
without a doubt said we made him a full
VP when he was only 26 years old and
he's been talking to us about getting
into the outpatient business back in the
early 80s if you had an accident or you
needed fiscal therapy after a surgery
the physician would just keep you in the
hospital as an inpatient you would
receive your therapy as an inpatient
even back then the cost of healthcare
was a
big concern Richards concept was get the
patient out of the hospital as fast as
you can I will certainly eliminate the
room and board portion of the hospital
bill and the patient would rather go
home and go back as an outpatient rather
than staying in a building full of sick
people and he felt like the therapist
would rather work in that kind of
environment rather than in the hospital
itself in the hospital the doctors and
the nurses are kind of the big dudes the
therapy departments are kind of off in
the basement somewhere and don't get
that much recognition and Richard felt
like if you put them in their own free
standing outpatient center they're like
working there better he convinced
Citicorp to put a million dollars into
his startup company and he wanted me to
be his CFO to help build a company
hopefully one day would go public but I
didn't want to I've had about enough of
Richard he's just he wears on you know
and he sees he manages by intimidation
and I really kind of wanted to get away
from him even at that point but he said
look Karen said put in $5,000 you've got
a hundred thousand shares of stock
Nicola share
he said I'm putting in twenty five
thousand I'm gonna get five hundred
thousand shares and you got to realize
Citicorp is paying dollars Sheriff for
their million shares so today your
nickel is already worth a dollar and I
didn't have a job I was going to be laid
off and I believe Richard could do it I
believe I was impressed that he got City
court to put the million dollars in and
it was almost on the back of an envelope
over dinner that he cut the deal no
formal business plan or anything and I
felt like he really could run a big
company and take it public so I said
okay I'm in Richard was from Alabama he
was born and raised in Selma Alabama so
he wanted to start the company up in
Birmingham
and we moved to Birmingham and we opened
our first outpatient center and it
looked more like a fitness
our spa or something that and that was
part of our concept was to make it
non-medical as much as possible so that
the patient feels like they're going to
a spa or something rather than getting
medical treatment we opened our first
Center and it started seeing patients
right away we charge less than the acute
care hospitals and we were off and
running and we raise additional vintage
venture capital open more centers early
on though I came in one morning the work
probably only had maybe 15 people in the
corporate office in Richard had drawn
this stick-figure image up here and he
he said look these guys are pulling the
wagon
he said yeah a lot of you aren't really
hooked up some of you were riding in the
wagon this guy's pulling the wagon
backwards this guy's just kind of fat
and dumb and sitting on the sidelines
and he says I need you to all pull the
wagon and he left that drawing up and it
became a kind of a company motto to pull
the wagon and he had it reproduced and
as the years went by
it was flamed and was in the lobby of
every health cell facility next to a
picture of Richard Scrushy and it at the
end of the year if you were an
outstanding employee you got a hundred
shares of stock in a little red wagon it
was called the pulling the wagon award
we discovered as we started opening
these outpatient centers that there was
a need for rehabilitation hospitals
specialty hospitals where you don't go
for surgery you don't go there if you're
sick you go there if you're really hurt
or you you've had a bad stroke and you
need you still need nursing care so your
your inpatient in a hospital a rehab
hospital we also discovered that
outpatient surgery was becoming a big
business years ago a physician would not
cut on you if you are not in an acute
care hospital but as you're probably
aware things have changed technology has
changed and a large percentage of all
surgeries now are done
patient basis and we got into that
business so we we really had three basic
businesses raw rehab outpatient centers
hospitals and then outpatient surgery we
started the company in 1984 and by 1986
we were talking to investment bankers
about going public and I remember very
well we were meeting with the bankers
from Drexel Burnham you may not know and
the older people in the room know about
Drexel Burnham but we were meeting with
the Baker in we were discussing our
numbers and everything and he said look
you all must have a lot of start-up
costs he said how are you handling your
startup cost and I said well I'm
expensing it yeah
very conservative accounting just
writing it off as we incurred it and he
looked at Richard 9 he almost had a
twinkle in his eye and he said oh no he
said you should be capitalizing those
costs he said I think that can get you
public just as soon as you show a profit
because you have a great concept but he
said y'all be capitalizing those
expenses and get profitable quickly and
we'll take you public and Richard looked
at me and he said Aaron why are you
letting the accounting tail wag the dog
he says your blankety-blank conservative
accounting is holding us back and he
said you should be doing this he said I
can't believe you're hurt you're hurting
me I'm trying to get this company public
and your conservative accounting is
holding us back
that's kind of how Richard managed if he
could get you down he would really beat
on you so to speak
so I've restated our numbers redid our
projections and sure enough in the
second quarter of 1986 we made a profit
in the banker said let's go so we went
on our Roadshow we went to New York
Boston Chicago San Francisco LA all of
the big institutional buyers in these
cities and we had a Roadshow and we
presented the stock to investors the
last road shows typically in New York
City the night before you price the
stock and or the day before in luncheon
richard made this just outstanding
presentation and at the end of his
presentation he got a standing ovation
and the guy sitting next to me so I'm
never seeing things like this
he said normally people don't applaud to
these types of presentations and he says
all my years on Wall Street I've never
seen anyone get a standing ovation he
said you guys should not be going public
your company is only two years old
your top-line audited is only five
million dollars you and Richard have no
experience running a public company
there are no other companies quite like
you out there so the analysts are going
to have trouble writing research on you
but he said clearly you're going to go
public Richard it's such a Salesman that
he'll pull it off sure enough we were
priced to go out at eight to ten dollars
a share and the deal got done at 6:50 we
barely made it
it was almost pulled at the last minute
but we got public began trading and it
was very exciting
I was called my broker every 15 minutes
to see how the stock was doing and
within a few months we were a ten dollar
stock you can do the arithmetic I had a
hundred thousand shares I'm now a
millionaire and the money changed me as
the years went by I bought a condo in
the French Quarter I bought a beach
house in Florida over the years about
thirty thousand dollars worth of these
air means neckties they're really
good-looking neckties you have to admit
but I went kind of crazy on that and it
certainly changed Richard Richard's ego
now was on steroids he formed a
rock-and-roll band called proxy and he
began playing it company functions and
even at music festivals and nightclubs
and he wanted to become a rock star and
the band didn't do that well so he
formed a country band and he went to
Nashville and he hired musicians to back
him and he actually wrote a song called
Hulk if you like the honky-tonk
and he sent memos out to all of our
employees asking them to call the road
radio stations and recommend his song be
played and he was just unbelievable he
also started always carrying a gun in
his briefcase and he hired bodyguards
that followed him everywhere
even if he went to Walmart or whatever
he was his bodyguards would be behind
him speaking into their sleeves and he
almost became kind of a Hannibal Lecter
kind of person he didn't looks a little
bit like Hannibal Lecter but it was just
amazing what what the money did to him
in spite of all this though he was the
darling of Wall Street he had started a
company that became started an entire
niche in health care and everybody
wanted him on their board of directors
venture capitalists brought him other
deals to invest in he just absolutely
was a darling of Wall Street and he
became very wealthy he controlled the
Board of Directors so when I got 10,000
options he got a million that kind of
thing
in 1995 less than ten years after
starting the company I estimated from
his public Leon stopped in HealthSouth
and other companies he was worth six
hundred million dollars
and he told the Birmingham News
newspaper that he wanted to be a
billionaire he was well on his way and
he was really that was his goal to be as
rich as he could be to be a billionaire
he'll south did very well we did lots of
public offerings we about six companies
went public in the same business we were
in and we began buying up our
competitors we did pooling of interest
we'd buy their stock with our stock and
by 1995 we were the largest company in
Alabama the state of Alabama we were
operating in all 50 states we have 50
thousand employees we were a fortune 500
company and I was a rock star in
Birmingham I could go into any
restaurant and people would point at me
want to talk to me it was just amazing
and it was it was quite the lifestyle we
started buying jet airplanes we had two
Gulfstream airplanes which are about
thirty million dollar airplanes many
mornings Richard and I would go to our
hangar get on our Gulfstream who would
have a stir discuss breakfast as we flew
in a Teterboro Airport in New Jersey
we'd get off the airplane there'd be a
helicopter waiting for us we get on the
helicopter flying in the Manhattan
there'd be a limo waiting for us we'd go
to the Plaza Hotel for Charlie Sheen
hangs out and make presentations to
investors and fly back home that night
never going through Atlanta or anything
it was really quite the lifestyle
Richard obsession with being wealthy was
unbelievable and he was the one that
really talked to the analysts and
investment bankers about what kind of
earnings we could achieve and he
understood that his wealth was tired of
Wall Street and he would ask the Ellis
what do we need to do for y'all to keep
a strong buy on the stock and they would
tell it no you need to grow 30 40
percent and he we can do that everything
was okay for the first seven eight nine
years we would hit those what he
promised the street but he got difficult
we were a big company out there weren't
as many growth opportunities and just
compound growth of 20 30 % it's
difficult to achieve year after year
after year so we started doing some
not-so-good accounting in health care
the biggest issue that the trick is
revenue recognition which it is in many
businesses you have contracts with HMOs
Medicare private companies you have a
lot of bad debt so what you charge the
patient and what you eventually collect
are very different so you have to make
adjust
but stuff that revenue to come up with a
net receivable number that's a good
number as it became difficult to make
our numbers maybe we miss the street
estimates by a penny we would say well
maybe bad debts aren't ten percent of
revenue they're going to be eight
percent and we would change that our
basis for the accounting for bad debts
not fraud certainly not good accounting
for those of you who are accounting
majors you understand you don't change
your underlying accounting principles to
achieve a number you change those
principles when it really dictates the
circumstances say you should but we did
it to make our numbers everything was
fine until 1996 ten years of being a
public company and we'd complete there
our second quarter and we'd missed our
numbers really badly and the street was
picking up that our days in a yard were
growing or cash flow didn't seem to be
what it should be and Bill Owens who was
my chief accountant and I just felt like
we could not play with the reserves
anymore just be too transparent and it
was time to report a bad quarter we went
into Richards office and we showed him
the numbers and we told him he said no
and you guys lost your minds he said we
can't do that he said the analysts are
going to put cells on the stock it's
going to crash we're going to be sued by
stockholders your stock options are
going to be worthless you're not going
to be the rock stars in Birmingham
anymore he said we can't we can't do
that and he said you know look he's
caught like he put on his cells
Manhattan he said now look health care
is the biggest business in the United
States we're a small part of it he said
we can get into the acute care hospital
business and become if not the largest
one of the largest companies in the
country but he said I can't do it if you
screw this up by reporting these bad
numbers and he said you've done things
to the numbers before you know capital
and calls changing estimates he said
there's got to be something you can do
to get past this little bump in the road
and Bill Owens who had my chief
accountant who had worked for our
auditors said Richard he said look we
have 1,500 general Ledger's he said I
can make entries small enough that the
auditors will look at them and he was
very clear he said I will be crediting
revenue that doesn't exist and debiting
assets that don't exist I was
intimidated by Richard I'm ashamed to
admit it but I did not have the courage
to stand up to him at that point I knew
he had a gun in his briefcase I had seen
him get so angry about small things that
I could not think of causing his net
worth to go down by several hundred
million dollars and I believed in the
company we were a good company and I
wanted I wanted the party to keep going
on I'll be honest with you I did not
want to report bad numbers either so
that night Bill Owens cooked the books I
told my wife about it when I went home
and she told me how stupid I was and
that night of course I couldn't sleep I
woke up the next day and I felt like I
had to put a genie back in a bottle in
and of course I couldn't and in that
point in my life changed I was now
living a lie we had cooked the books the
next quarter rolls around and we do it
again not quite as difficult the second
time 1996 ends I lied to the auditors
when they asked their standard questions
about have any interest been made or not
made that should have been made and sure
enough we got it by the auditors it
wasn't discovered 1997 begins and we
plead with Richard to lower street
expectations and he had no part of it he
knew that once you're a high p/e
high-growth company
you tell the street you're not going to
keep growing they'll they'll put cells
or at least holes on the stock rather
than strong buys so we began 1997 and it
was apparent to me that we were going to
have another year of cooking the books
because we were in a hold we had to get
out of the hole and then grow
unrealistically during this period of
time I think it was early 1997 Richard
told Bill Owens and I he said if we're
ever caught I will deny everything you
guys do what you want but I'm telling
you I'm going to deny everything well my
life is an utter mess I'm beginning to
drink more than I should I hate my job I
hate going to work every day and I felt
trapped you know I didn't want to be a
whistleblower with Richard making that
statement I knew he would bring more
lawyers guns and money to the party than
I would I didn't want to stay because it
was not fun anymore it was a lie
so I went to Richard and I told him I
wanted to retire I was only 54 years old
and he said yeah that's what you want to
do he said say I think you're making a
mistake but that's what you want to do
and we never talked about the Frog and
Richards very smart you don't have to
spell things out to him so I left the
company in 1997 and I moved to South
Alabama close to coast and about as soon
as I was not an insider anymore I sold
all my stock and about 15 25 acres of
land and I built a very nice house and
for some reason I built a football field
in my backyard and to this date I don't
know if anyone else built I mean had
goalposts and everything yeah so and I
just distance myself from the company I
just put it out of my mind in but one
day about a year after I retired Richard
called me he said come to Birmingham
have lunch with me so I went to
Birmingham and
I went into the dining room of the
corporate offices and he said look Aaron
I need you to come back to work he said
that we're making our numbers fine now
he said everything's okay you need to
come back and help me grow the company
and I told him no I really did not want
to get back into the frying pan and I
was having a lot of fun my dogs on my
football field so I went back in 1998
passes 1999 2000 2001 2002 but in the
spring of 2003 I'm watching The Evening
News and they open up with we have a
breaking story out of Birmingham Alabama
massive accounting fraud uncovered it
hell sell billions of bogus entries have
been made to the books and I was like
shocked when I first retired every time
my doorbell rang or my phone rang I
thought it was the FBI I thought it was
you know but it'd been six years and I
wanted to believe the fraud had stopped
so I I I'm sure was surprised his
average guy on the street but I was
amazed that the fraud had gone on all
those years
Alice Martin who was the attorney with
the federal government out of the
Northern District of Alabama the
newspaper the next day said several
people have come forward admitted their
involvement in the fraud but there are
others that are involved and if you're
one of those people you need to come
forward and I almost thought she was
going to name me by name in the paper
but our wife tried to console me and say
look you've been gone a long time
fraud wasn't that big when you were
there they're not going to come after
you no I don't I don't think so and so I
contacted an attorney a white-collar
criminal attorney and he knew Alice
Martin's people he made some phone calls
and he called me back and he said oh
yeah mr. Behm you need to come talk to
me so my wife and I went in and first
thing he said he says do not lie to me
and do not lie to the federal government
he says your
armored employees have told them you
were involved the FBI is all over that
building and if you lie they're going to
come down on you like a freight train
you need to tell the truth by now my
wife is in tears I'm almost in tears and
I have a kind of funny sense of humor I
asked him if he needed a check or
something
he said yes I like for you to write me a
check for $100,000 on the cloud you got
to be kidding it's a no mister him I
like kidding so that won't be the last
check you have to write and I asked him
if I could get a t-shirt or something
and he gave me a coffee mug and my wife
and I referred to it as $100,000 coffee
mug three days later I'm in a Federal
Building in Birmingham Alabama and I'm
sitting across the table from two FBI
agents two agents from the SEC several
attorneys from Alice Martin's office and
I am a scared puppy it is not fun to be
interrogated by the FBI and the SEC and
I felt like I didn't do a good job
because they wanted to know well in 1996
when you first cook the books what do
you say - Richard What did he say to you
they're recording all this and I
couldn't remember I couldn't remember
details but at the end of the day it
lasted all day the FBI agent said mr.
bean he said we know a lot about this
case and from what we know we believe
you were very truthful today and he says
we we appreciate that Alice Martin's
people said seventeen people have come
forward and admitted their involvement
in the fraud only one key person denies
it Richard Scrushy
he says he knows nothing about it and
we're going to have to take mr. sheet of
trial and we would like for you to be a
witness and they explained that they
weren't cutting me a deal that wouldn't
like rat Richard out and you don't go to
prison all we can tell you that if you
cooperate when we recommend a sentencing
to a federal judge will ask him to take
that into consideration
this is a spring of Oh to the trial
didn't begin until oh five in January so
I had a two-year period where my life
was literally very very miserable I knew
I could possibly go to prison for north
of 20 years basically the rest of my
life in my attorney explained to me that
they're going to look at your personal
balance sheet and because of the
magnitude of the fraud they can find you
whatever they want to find you and
they're not going to put you in a box
underneath a freeway but you're not
going to have a football field and a
million dollar home and a home in
Florida all that you're going to have to
sell that to pay pay the government so
it like I say it was a very very dark
period of time during this period of
time Richard Scrushy when told the
offensive he left the church that he
belonged to and he joined an inner city
church and he gave that church a million
dollars he also bought a television
station in Birmingham and he and his
wife every morning Monday through Friday
preached the gospel on TV he was a or a
preacher he spent twenty million dollars
of his lawyers
he hired a jury selection firm he had a
publicist and all during the trial he
every day he was always had a Bible in
his hand he and his wife and he was
surrounded by ministers and I thought it
was laughable I just didn't think it's
so obvious what he was trying to do I
just didn't think it would work the
government wanted me to be the first
witness there were four CFOs after I
left all promoted up in the company and
they wanted me to be the first witness
because they thought I was very
professor like I guess it's the beard I
don't know and that I could explain to
the jury what street estimates were what
our earnings per share what our what's
the balance sheet what's an income
statement and sure enough they put me on
the stand and they have charts and it
goes on almost all day and
the jury is falling asleep I'm trying to
make eye contact and they they don't get
they're bored they don't understand it
they literally were falling asleep I
could have been teaching rocket science
or brain surgery they were picked up on
it just as well that's what I was doing
now this is big-time courtroom drama
this was the first Czar Baines Oxley
case tried in the United States and it
was a big deal you don't want to be
Farzin something like this if you don't
have to very first things lawyer gets my
face he says mr. bean you've had an
extramarital affair hemorrhaging I say
yes because I had the next day the
Birmingham News the newspaper said what
a clever her attorney he was to get me
to admit to this and the next day my
wife wanted to come to the courtroom
holding a sign saying she still loved me
and we've been married 40 years now and
I have since discovered that he's on his
fourth wife and the fourth wife is very
much of trophy bride I did grass on he
didn't get to my face he says Mr Bean
when you went to New York City and
presented to investors you lied didn't
you
when you presented the numbers to the
Board of Directors you lied mr. bean you
lie so much you don't know when you're
telling the truth you are a cheat and a
liar
the jurors eyes were this big they were
awake they were having fun this was
entertainment Heather's lawyer screaming
at me and called me a liar the trial
went on for six months the jury
deliberated for about six weeks
not guilty all charged the legal
community throughout the United States
could not believe it
Enron world calm Tyco Martha Stewart
they all went to prison but not Richard
Scrushy within a couple of weeks he flew
to Houston Texas to coach Ken Lay on how
to conduct his trial at Enron
unbelievable they asked the jury
some of the ones that were willing to
talk to asked him how did you find mr.
screw she not guilty when 17 people five
CFOs all said he was at the center of
the fraud in some of them said well it
seemed like those CFOs were liars and
mr. screw she seemed like a nice
Christian man I cried like a baby when
it went verdict went down I just could
not believe that he had pulled it off
three months later I was sentenced to
federal prison and I got only three
months and I'm I don't understand why I
got such a like sentence but I'm CUBAN
and I do not volunteer to do more time
so I don't know if any of y'all been to
prison but if you got to go to prison
you want to go to a federal minimum
security prison it's not that bad my
wife drove me there I've reported it was
on an Air Force Base and you're not
locked up per se and they actually tell
you if you want to leave you can but
they say when the marshals US marshals
catch you you're going to Big Boy person
and I didn't want to go to big-boy
prison so interesting place presents
like this were initially set up I think
for white-collar criminals and there
were a lot of lawyers and accountants
there was two beds down for me where we
slept there was a thoracic surgeon that
cheated the Medicare program the most
interesting guy I met while I was there
was the father of the young man that
just married Chelsea Clinton he was a
politician he was in for seven years for
I think embezzling campaign funds or
something nice guys very interesting
about half of the prison those drug
dealers if you're a non-violent drug
dealers and you get less than 10 years
you can go to this kind of prison so
it's kind of 50/50 white-collar and drug
dealing I was they were doing football
season and I'm a big LSU fan and did I
tell you I think we're going to play in
a bowl game okay
one night LSU was playing and it was on
TV and there's a television set in the
lobby for your house and up until 10
o'clock at night you can watch
television so I went in to watch the
game and there were a bunch of drug
dealers and there they were watching the
Miami Hurricanes play and they called me
pops it's and now pops you're not
watching your Tigers we're going to
watch our Cain's but and I was depressed
I went around every barracks trying to
find a TV but you're not supposed to do
and to watch the game and all the drug
dealers have them tied up the season
ends LSU gets an invitation go to the
Peach Bowl and Atlanta Georgia to play
the Miami Hurricanes oh boy I get to see
this game so the night before the game
three of these guys came to me and
they're their biggest football players
because they're they're in and out of
prison they lift weights and they're
huge and they asked me for my shoelaces
that's why they said so you won't hang
yourself when Miami kicks LSU last
market so the game begins it's me and
xxx drug dealers from Miami and LSU wins
40 to 3 and it was absolutely the most
fun I could possibly have while you're
in prison the worst thing about it there
was no body there with violence in their
background so the first night I took a
shower I looked over my shoulder and
nothing happened but the worst part was
the food I happened to read the book
Fast Food Nation while I was in there
and they they talked about how the very
worst grade of all food goes to prisons
and after being there about a week I got
the right to call my wife and I called
her and I told her I was telling her on
and over how bad the food was and she
said Aaron you're in prison
so I didn't complain about food anymore
I got out in February and I'm now a
felon do you know what the job market is
like for felons ok it's not good you can
imagine in today's job market
if there's a good job opening there's
got to be 30 40 50 people that qualify
for it apply what chance does a felon
have so I needed a job my fines and my
legal bills were well in excess of a
million dollars and I had to auction off
my property and I needed a job my wife
had gone back to work
I had always liked gardening and working
outdoors and I went back to school and I
got a two-year certificate in turf
management and for the past few years
I've been making a living mowing the
lawns it's not that bad except the heat
in South Alabama during the summer is
just terrible and but when I was that
life larkey are not like more he'll sell
now salary was $500,000 I really didn't
feel like I was earning that money there
were 50,000 employees out there making
that money for me but today when I mow
lawns cut somebody's grass and I get
maybe 40 or 50 dollars in the South
Alabama heat I feel like I've really
earned that money
and it's uh I do sleep better now than I
ever did when I was at HealthSouth my
wife is so smart she said I thought you
called the Dean of the business school
over the years I've given them a lot of
money and see if you could talk to the
MBA students about what has happened to
you and I do like talking so I called
the Dean and the Dean said oh yeah I
think that'd be a good idea so I went
talk to the MBA students they had a
special session for me and it went very
well I really felt like I had done
something right and but I didn't think
about doing speaking as a as a living
doing it for a living in line WorldCom
Tyco HealthSouth it all faded into the
woodwork there weren't front-page news
anymore but something happened you know
y'all may have heard about the subprime
debacle we learned that millions of
loans were made to people mortgage
company
he's coached people how to lie on their
loan applications to get be able to buy
a home they really couldn't afford Wall
Street took those loans packaged them
told it got them rated very highly
standard & poor's and moody's and they
told the investing public these were
good securities on the other side of the
house they're hedge funds were shorting
these securities the real estate bubble
burst and all of a sudden I mean it's
almost overnight you've lived it the
largest insurance companies the largest
banks the largest investment banking
firms are all broke and they're asking
for a bailout and we're in the Great
Recession why at the heart of it is
greed an unethical business behavior
hell self was bad but this was massive
so massive that it put the whole world
into a recession the Great Recession
when Webster's first published his
dictionary he defines success as being
generous prosperous healthy and kind
today that definition is the attainment
of wealth Fame and rank having a bigger
house and more cars in your neighbor
when you're up to here in debt is not
being successful particularly if you
accumulate that wealth by doing
unethical business things so I have been
speaking to colleges and companies and
associations fraud associations and
accounting groups about ethics and you
might say and I'm sure you had said this
you can't teach ethics you're either
ethical or you're not I don't believe
it's that black or white I believe it's
like the pilot that landed that plane on
the Hudson River
he studied every crash every water
landing and he knew in those critical
moments exactly what to do and how to
bring that plane in and save those
people's lives I think today if we teach
ethics at high schools colleges on the
job
you'll be better prepared to deal with
the kind of things I had to deal with
and trust me you will when you get out
into the business world you will face
things like I face maybe not as big but
you will be asked to keep cells open a
little longer after the month II and
maybe cut payables off a little early to
help the bottom line I think the image
of the accountant with the green visor
in the backroom is if for sport true the
hard-charging people are in sales
they're in marketing they're out front
they like confrontation I tell it's like
to kind of be in the background in
please people by keeping a nice set of
books in that that hurts you the largest
turnover of executives in the United
States of CFO's CFO of public companies
only last three and a half years and
part of it it's because they're
constantly asked to make the numbers
what they need to be in it's really
really a big problem and you need to be
aware of that you need when you go to
work for a company and you figure out
you've got a sociopath at the top like
Richard Scrushy and the tone at the top
is all wrong you need to leave that
company and go to another company I'll
come back there there's a professor
Arizona State University dr. Mary Ann
Jennings and she's probably one of the
outstanding ethics professors in the
United States and she has written a book
called the seven signs of ethical
collapse and the book is about Enron
world calm Tyco and HealthSouth and she
talks about the seven things to look for
in a company before it has a complete
ethical meltdown the first sign is the
pressure to maintain the numbers make
the numbers and it helps out that was
our our whole focus make the numbers no
matter what make the numbers but if the
culture is such that it's make the
numbers with no regard for doing it
ethically doing correctly
that's the first
the second sign is fear in silence
Richard managed by intimidation and most
people don't want to tell them their
boss they're afraid they'll lose their
job so there's a culture of fear and
silence in these companies you might
think my whole speech today is the
bashing of Richard Scrushy but you've
got to realize that when you have an
Enron or a world comma or HealthSouth
the guy at the top the CEO is probably a
bigger-than-life personality who hires
young people or people that he can
control and manage and intimidate and
get them to do what he wants the fourth
sign is a weak Board of Directors and
this is probably the most important
certainly back in the HealthSouth era
dr. Jennings said that HealthSouth had
the weakest board of directors he had
ever seen just absolutely any time
Richard put somebody on the board and
they gave him in in trouble he just got
rid of it so over the years he just
developed a board of yes-men the board
it
WorldCom was referred to as Bernie's
boys Burnie Evers was chairman of the
board and it was his boys conflicts
Richard made sure we all have stock
options we were giving loans to exercise
our stock options we did business with
our board member of about eight million
dollars worth a glass from a guy that to
go into our hospitals he was on the
board so Richard set us up to be
conflicted so we stay true to the cause
innovation like no other I challenge
anybody this room to explain to us what
Enron really did nobody understood
Enron's business had this unique
business the unique thing to like no
other thing at HealthSouth where it was
our earnings for ten years we went
perfectly straight up note no bumps at
all people sometimes look look hard at
companies when they're doing badly but
all
these companies Enron HealthSouth they
were high-flying companies apparently
doing very well
but too well the last sign is goodness
in some areas atones for evil in other
areas it's kind of an interesting sign
but it's there in many cases HealthSouth
gave lots of money to churches and
schools and everything there were many
many things throughout the state of
Alabama Richard Scrushy name on it it
was HealthSouth money but he made sure
he gave money to these causes and he was
recognized as this very generous person
one last Richard Scrushy story because
it's the best one Richard has had three
wives and nine children and his third
wife was a graduate of Troy University
in South Alabama and they wanted to get
into division one football and they
needed to sell X number of season
tickets and they needed to enlarge their
stadium so he'll self bought the tickets
and gave them the money to in a large
sustained and sure enough it became the
Richard M Scrushy Stadium but he also
required that the band play his song
Hulk if you like to honky-tonk at
halftime unbelievable I have written a
book called HealthSouth the wagon to
disaster and you might say oh look at
Aaron beam he's up here preaching to us
about ethics and he's trying to get rich
off of a cookie but I don't know how
many of y'all have written a book you
may have doctor but the chances of you
writing a book and you become wealthy
from it is about as likely as you being
struck by lightning while you're on your
honeymoon with Cindy Crawford it's not
going to happen my speech is a condensed
version of the book and that's the
reason I wrote the book I hope
universities will have students read it
so they can understand how
that's all evolved how I got on the
slippery slope and how I made the
terrible decisions that I did today I am
a felon that's all ever going to be
remembered as I'm not going to be
remembered as got it started one of the
largest healthcare companies and more
than of the largest companies in Alabama
I'm going to be known as the guide that
cooked the books at HealthSouth you do
not want to go there
all that unethical behavior is very
corrosive it's it's like metal rusty one
day it rust more and more and more in a
bridge falls down people die if you let
yourself compromise your ethical
principles it will lead to a very bad
ending and that's that's the message I
want to bring today at this point I'd
like to throw it open questions they may
have a question yes sir he's in prison
believe it or not this is his mug shot
when he went to prison after the
government lost the case of Hell south
he was indicted for bribing the governor
of Alabama
the governor was running for re-election
while he was at HealthSouth and he gave
the governor or HealthSouth gave the
governor five hundred thousand dollars
for his campaign funds and the federal
government Richard got appointed to a
board CEO end certificate of need board
a public state position and the federal
government says this was a bribed legal
community said this is silly that people
give politicians money all the time and
it's seldom ever considered a bribe it's
just not well richard fired up his TV
show he got the Bible's back out got the
ministers in the courtroom and he was
found guilty and he's in a prison in
Beaumont Texas now and he's been there
for three years and he's doing seven
years I think you get one year knocked
off but uh they've asked him like what
is he going to do when he gets out and
he said he's going to continue preaching
and he's going to write
Tsing Christian music so you know get in
line for that album when it comes out I
haven't no I've had no contact with
don't want to I hope he lives by the
rules you can't own a gun when you're a
felon so right well we were in a bubble
of a stock market bubble in particularly
health care socks and part of it was
just like the home mortgage thing is you
rationalized that it's okay you know
because now it really didn't maybe
toward the end it got down to patient
care level but it was pretty much in the
board room and the day we did it we cook
the books you don't think about the
consequences
you don't look ahead and think oh my god
this is going to turn out very terribly
you're rationalizing you believe you're
doing the best choice you're picking the
best option by doing what you do white
collar criminals are like that I met an
FBI agent at a conference the other day
and it's very clear the the typical
criminal that holds up a bank with a gun
the money is in the bank he wants it
okay
the white-collar criminal though many
times rationalizes and convinces himself
that what you're doing is not really bad
you know if you can pull it off what the
heck
oh all of our accounting was centralized
so people sent all their financial
information and payrolls and everything
was done centrally so Bill Owens was a
very smart guy he was able to do it how
he pulled it off for all those years I
don't know the forensic accounting bill
to clean up the books of 643 million
dollars there were literally hundreds of
thousands of bogus entries made how the
auditors did not catch it I don't know I
wasn't surprised that they didn't catch
it the first year I was there but went
on the last audited balance sheet had
300 million in cash that didn't exist so
they weren't real good auditors
yes
you really should if you certainly if
you know it's fraudulent you know it's
fraud you should you should have
reported and you could be rewarded
handsomely the new dog bill I think you
get 30% of the fine that ultimately goes
down so a lot of controversy around that
with enough that's a good piece of
legislation or not but you certainly
should you should tell but it takes a
lot of courage it's the easy thing to do
is just walk away now
but if you know for sure that there's
out in this hotline some ways you can do
it and not be known well the 2010 errand
me was a lot smarter than he was back
then I would have thought what I said no
Richard we can't do this this is this is
pushing the envelope too far this is
fraud this is wrong and he would have
fired me I would have lost my job but I
should have done that and I would do it
today I might you get religion when you
go to president you the trick with a
person like Richard is that the
personality type of a CEO of real
hard-charging CEO if has a lot of the
traits that richard has you just need to
size them up and make sure they're not a
sociopath because it clearly if Richard
can sue me for anything probably me
calling sociopaths but he is he has no
conscience and you have to you have to
figure that out but you look at the
people what look at Donald Trump
I mean loves himself he loves being on
reality TV but everybody wants to go to
work for the dollar you know I'm not
saying Donald Trump is Richard Scrushy
but that person richer had the Donald
Trump type personality of loving himself
bill Owens got five years
Weston Smith who actually wrote chapter
10 in my book he got two years Mike
Martin the CFO that replaced me got
three years but really kind of light
sentences you know it if you've plead if
you come forward and plead and the
government doesn't have to take you to
court you do get a lot better deal all
of those guys myself if I had tried to
live through it and they had found me
guilty I probably would have gone to
prison for many many many years yeah
I'll stick around and okay thank you